From its ingenious sound design to a limited
use of gore to Jack Nicholson's iconic portrayal
of Jack Torrance, The Shining left a permanent
mark on horror.
Here's how The Shining changed horror movies
forever...and ever...and ever.
One of the ways The Shining stands out from
the horror crowd is through Stanley Kubrick's
hyper-realistic lens.
This terrifying tale is not told in the familiar
shadowy environment most horror movies prior
to 1980 had used to bump up the scare factor.
In fact, the majority of the film takes place
in broad daylight.
Add Kubrick's signature style to the mix,
and the result is one beautiful looking movie.
With common tropes out of the way, Kubrick's
signature sense of cinematic framing and lighting
helps to place the audience firmly into the
mood and world of the Overlook Hotel.
The story becomes accessible in a way that
many horror movies don't.
As supernatural as things become, this is
still a human story.
Kubrick nails this point home by presenting
each frame with a heightened sense of realism
that pushes psychological boundaries in a
way that's almost unnoticeable.
Everything seems fine.
"Little slow tonight, isn't it?
HAHAHAHA"
Disrupting this genre formula not only keeps
viewers on their toes, it also results in
a compelling story that never stops being
creepy.
The Shining made it clear that it was okay
to bring your monster into the light.
Not only does Stanley Kubrick focus on the
get-under-your-skin moments throughout The
Shining, but he also commits to creeping out
audiences through an unexpected use of sound
and silence.
As we've been reminded with the box office
success of A Quiet Place, silence can be a
major tool in amplifying a sense of dread
and danger.
There are moments throughout The Shining — following
Danny's tricycle through the Overlook's winding
hallways come to mind — where the audience
only hears the sounds of the wheels regularly
transitioning from the hard floor to the soft
carpet.
It's not much to watch, but as the camera
follows Danny, our perspective is minimized
and becomes childlike.
Add that to the unexpected sound cues of the
movie's score, and the results are quite unnerving.
The result finds the audience no longer receiving
warnings that the visual horrors are right
around the corner.
And with those guidelines thrown out of whack,
a steady stream of dread and anxiety comes
into play.
“No. ah.”
We've already mentioned the film's color palette
and uncharacteristic use of light and realism
to add to the terror, but The Shining doesn't
stop there.
What Stanley Kubrick pulled off is akin to
the other classics in his filmography: He
made a well produced, well-acted, well-written
film.
For decades, the horror genre has fought tooth
and nail to climb its way out of the jokey,
B-movie recesses that have remained its home.
At its heart, The Shining is the tale of a
family fractured as its patriarch descends
into madness.
It's a story that'd be easy enough to tell
under low-budget circumstances, but Kubrick
was a perfectionist.
He elevated the genre through cutting edge
methods and high-quality production.
These standards not only left an impact on
horror movies, they forever changed cinema.
Throughout The Shining, Kubrick focused more
on the personal demons Jack Torrance and his
son Danny were dealing with.
Yes, there are still spirits haunting the
hotel.
But their appearance here coincides with Jack's
own troubled past.
The ghost story is just the mask to the deeper,
more human horrors.
Using horror as an allegory for a real-life
issue is as old as the genre itself, but with
The Shining, Kubrick crafted a legitimately
terrifying film that works on all the potential
levels.
If you're scared of hotel ghosts, don't watch
The Shining.
And if a family man giving in to his addiction
in violent ways makes your knickers quake,
don't watch The Shining.
And while prior horror movies like Rosemary's
Baby and Night of the Living Dead were steeped
in allegory, The Shining's cultural impact
influenced modern horror filmmakers to give
their movies depth that goes beyond jump scares.
One of the biggest horror movies in recent
years, Get Out, explores its themes in similar
ways, and director Jordan Peele hasn't been
quiet about drawing from The Shining for that.
He went so far as to admit that he even, quote,
"totally ganked" the opening title credit.
"It's a f------ hedge maze out here."
In the same vein, The Witch director Robert
Eggers told SlashFilm:
"When I watch The Witch, sometimes I’m a
little disgusted by how much of my film flagrantly
reeks of The Shining.
At the same time, I will admit that if it
wasn’t for that, I don’t think the film
would be working for people at all."
Before The Shining hit theaters, a popular
trope explored in horror was that of "The
Evil Child."
From the Twilight Zone episode "It's a Good
Life" to films like Village of the Damned
and The Omen, the creepy child motif had been
a strong one in genre entertainment.
It still is, but The Shining represented the
beginning of a transition.
Suddenly, movies started paying less attention
to the young Antichrist wreaking havoc at
home, and focused more on telling empowered
tales of survival and redemption through the
innocent perspective of the children themselves.
In putting Danny Torrance in a position of
power — with the help of Dick Hallorann
showing him the how to "shine" the boy became
the beacon of hope throughout the entire film.
"You've got the shinning.“
“You mean Shining...
“shhh do you wanna get sued?"
As the '80s progressed and films like A Nightmare
on Elm Street, It, and The Goonies arrived,
the trend of empowered children gaining the
upper hand against the evil adults of the
world grew exponentially.
Kubrick's The Shining flipped the proverbial
script, turning this adult/child dynamic on
its head.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.